On April 17, 1955, the
greatest scientist of his generation checked
himself into Princeton Hospital due to chest
pains.
By early the next morning, Albert Einstein
had died from an abdominal aortic aneurysm
– the rupture of the aorta, the heart vessel
that’s the body’s main supplier of blood.
While word was still getting out that the
great Dr. Einstein had passed away at the
age of 76, something rather disturbing was
happening at the hospital, if not downright
nefarious.
Einstein’s brain, the keeper of one of the
world’s greatest intellects, had been stolen.
And that is just the beginning of the story.
Dr. Thomas Stolz Harvey was the pathologist
on call during the early morning hours of
the 18th and was the doctor assigned to attend
to Dr. Einstein.
Seven hours after the great scientist’s
death at 1 am, Harvey began the autopsy he
claimed he was given permission to do.
After determining the cause of death, Harvey
went about removing, measuring, and weighing
Einstein’s brain.
Harvey later would say that he "knew we had
permission to do an autopsy, and I assumed
that we were going to study the brain.”
To this day, no paperwork nor permission prior
to the autopsy has ever been found.
After all the calculations had been done,
Dr. Harvey interjected and immersed the brain
in formaldehyde.
After he was done with that, he took Einstein’s
eyeballs out, which were later given to Einstein’s
eye doctor Henry Adams (rumors still exist
that the eyeballs are in a safe deposit box
somewhere in New York City).
Finally, he gave the rest of the body back
to be cremated.
The removal of the brain and eyeballs were
against Einstein’s final wishes.
According to to Brian Burrell’s book Postcards
from the Brain Museum, Einstein had left very
specific instructions.
He wanted to be cremated with the brain still
inside of his head and his ashes scattered
in secret, in order to "discourage idolaters."
So not only was this against Einstein’s
personal wishes, Harvey had no legal nor medical
right for keeping the brain.
He wasn’t even a neurosurgeon nor a brain
specialist.
His responsibility simply was to determine
the cause of death – which was heart failure
and had very little to do with brain (at least,
directly).
Burrell speculates that there were two possible
reasons for Harvey to remove and keep for
himself one of history’s most famous brains
– one is that it was at the request of Harry
Zimmerman, Einstein’s personal physician
and a mentor of Harvey.
Zimmerman never publicly said this to be true,
though did he make the request for the brain
after the deed was done.
The other theory that Burrell gives is that
Harvey, perhaps inspired by the study done
on Lenin’s brain in 1926, simply got “caught
up in the moment and was transfixed in the
presence of greatness.";
Whatever the case, on April 19th, after the
removal and storing of the brain, Harvey went
about asking for permission retroactively
from Einstein’s son, Hans Albert Einstein.
Hans Albert granted the permission, making
Harvey promise that his father’s mind would
be used for careful scientific study and the
findings published in legitimate medical journals.
When the New York Times printed Einstein’s
obituary on April 20th, it said that Dr. Harvey
performed the autopsy “with the permission
of the scientist’s son," with another headline
that same day proclaiming “Son Asked Study
of Einstein Brain."
It makes no mention that this permission came
after the fact.
When word got out that Harvey had the brain,
requests came flooding in from across the
world from others who wanted to see and study
it.
As mentioned, one request came from Dr. Harry
Zimmerman in New York, whom Harvey promised
would get the first chance to study it.
Zimmerman and his hospital in New York prepared
for Harvey and the brain, but it never showed.
A short time later, it was announced by Princeton
Hospital that the brain would stay in New
Jersey.
“Snarl Develops Over Which Hospital Will
Conduct Einstein Brain Study," was a headline
in the Washington Post, while another newspaper
went with “Hospitals Tiff over Brain of
Einstein."
The controversy over ownership of Einstein’s
brain had become a circus and it was about
to get even more bizarre.
Technically, Princeton Hospital never really
had possession of the brain.
Dr. Harvey did.
He kept it in a jar in his home office.
Soon after the public spat with Dr. Zimmerman
and with still no medical studies on the brain
underway, Dr. Harvey was fired from Princeton
Hospital.
He took the brain with him.
Harvey went to the University of Pennsylvania,
and with help of a technician, cut up the
brain into a thousand slides and 240 blocks,
putting them into squares of celluloid – a
semi-solid plastic-like substance.
He finally gave some of the pieces to Dr.
Zimmerman and kept the remainder of Albert
Einstein’s brain in two formalin-filled
glass jars for himself.
Other researchers made overtures about wanting
the rest of the brain, but Harvey refused
to let go – insisting that he was “a year
from finishing study on the specimen."
Harvey’s marriage fell apart and he quickly
packed his bags to get out of Princeton, bound
for the midwest.
Before he could leave, his (ex) wife threatened
to “dispose" of the brain.
Of course, Harvey didn’t let this happen
and took it with him as he made his way to
Wichita, Kansas, where he worked as a medical
supervisor in a biological testing lab.
Legendarily, during his time in Wichita, he
kept Einstein’s brain in a cider box underneath
a beer cooler.
For the next thirty years, Harvey moved around
the Midwest, towing the brain along, never
publishing any studies.
Every once in awhile, a researcher would contact
him and he would send them a slide or two,
hoping they could do the research he never
did.
A few times, the story of Einstein’s brain
drew the public’s attention again, especially
after a 1978 article in the regional magazine
New Jersey Monthly by Steven Levy.
Said Levy about his first experience with
Harvey and the brain,
At first he didn’t want to tell me anything,
but after a while he finally admitted that
he had the brain.
After a longer while, he sheepishly told me
it was IN THE VERY OFFICE WE WERE SITTING
IN.
He walked to a box labeled “Costa Cider"
and pulled out two big Mason jars.
In those were the remains of the brain that
changed the world.
Another documented interaction comes from
Kenji Sugimoto, a Japanese professor and Einstein
expert, who visited Harvey in Kansas:
Humbly, the professor asks if he maybe could
bring a piece back with him to Japan."Sure,
why not," Harvey replies and walks out to
the kitchen to fetch his bread board and a
knife.
Harvey finds an old pill cup to store the
slice in and pours a little formaldehyde in.
In 1985, three decades after Einstein’s
death, someone finally published a study on
Einstein’s brain after receiving slides
from Harvey – Marian Diamond of UCLA.
Published in Experimental Neurology, her study
was (admittedly) far from conclusive, but
it did speculate that Einstein’s brain had
more glial cells for every neuron than a normal
brain.
This could mean that the cells had a greater
“metabolic need" – meaning more energy
was used and needed, which it was speculated
could also mean an increase in conceptual
and thinking skills.
While recent research may have debunked this
theory, there were finally studies about Einstein’s
stolen brain published in legitimate medical
journals.
Yet, this still wasn’t the end to the brain’s
journey.
In 1988, Thomas Harvey had his medical license
revoked when he failed a three day competency
exam in Missouri.
A few years later, he returned to Princeton,
only to be convinced by writer Michael Paterniti
to go meet Einstein’s granddaughter in California.
Of course, he had to bring the brain.
In Paterniti’s book Driving Mr. Albert,
it describes, with the jars of brain in a
duffle-bag in the trunk of Harvey’s Buick
Skylark, their drive to sunny California.
They did, indeed, meet Evelyn Einstein in
Berkeley, where Harvey forgot the brain at
her house when he left.
She returned it to him, not wanting anything
to do with it.
Thomas Harvey passed away in 2007, but before
he did, he donated the brain to the Princeton
Hospital, the same place that the brain began
its extra-curricular journey over fifty years
prior.
Public interest once again increased and researchers,
who had received slides of Einstein’s brain
over the years, sent them back to Princeton
and the University of Pennsylvania (where
they were originally cut).
Today, the Mutter Museum in Philadelphia is
only place in the world one can currently
see pieces of Einstein’s brain (slides were
also once on display in 2013 in
the National Museum of Health and Medicine
in Maryland) – on slides, stained, and with
handwritten notes from Thomas Harvey.